valtra autret y possède une énergie
extraordinaire
débordante d'activité cette amoureuse
des animaux vend aussi de petits objets
dans les fêtes foraines de lille mais
l'ancien enseignant d'origine allemand
de qualité et surtout connu pour les
deux livres qu'elle a édité des
biographies puiser dans ses journaux
intimes témoin d'une existence riche en
souvenirs ceux de l'allemagne nazie puis
de sa propre conception de la vie au fil
de ses voyages un cheminement
philosophique et spirituelle qui lui ont
forgé un regard réaliste et positif sur
la perception humaine est ce son devenir
parce que c'était très difficile pour
vous de puiser dans votre passé pour
pouvoir être à vos livres pas tellement
justement à cause de ses journaux
intimes que j'ai tenu et la danger les
anecdotes qui sont on va passer les
lagons sous le régime nazi tout ça tout
ça jamais j'ai puisé l'adage j'ai
recopié je pourrais dire encore plus mal
et n'a pas été difficile et ses jours ne
vous en suivait partout oui et puis la
pression férus de toile à un cependant
la suite parce qu on a ses lecteurs de
là devant les rusés vous dites que vous
êtes une ex allemande oui pourquoi mais
on va croiser souvent la question
sentimentale mots je suis encore helmand
le jem les noël allemand j'aime la
musique allemande j'aime ma famille est
ou ce qui en reste et j'aime l'allemagne
en temps mais j'ai tellement j'ai
tellement eu des infos comment dirais je
ne trouve pas le mot
scandalisé par le hitler et les nazis
que je peux pas m'identifier identifié
complètement en tant qu'allemand de
compagnie mais mon corps maintenant mais
les gens lisent aujourd'hui c'est la
troisième génération les jeunes
allemands ils sont pas d'un coup ils
savent à peine comment ça s'est passé
mais il faut qu'ils sachent et c'est pas
beau si forte que ça recommence une
chose comme ça pour revenir à votre
enfance vous avez quand même eu une
enfance dorée attraits de rêver oui
choyés oui très ce que vous avez à ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous refusez ça oui elle
est très reconnaissante
très reconnaissante au destin qui m'a
fait naître dans une famille assure unis
est très aisé et puis dans un château il
s'en passe bon c'est pas ma faute je
vous êtes informés d'un mais après après
45 j'ai vécu comme une mendiante je
fouille dans les poubelles pour manger
je n'avais plus rien blayac jour au
lendemain ça peut arriver à n'importe
qui ça et après je fais les études
surmonter maintenant j'ai une vie qui me
plaît beaucoup et ça partait de ces
péripéties justement que vous avez
travailler tout ces petits lots sophie
intérieur oui une prise de conscience de
la vraie nature humaine nous absolument
oui les au sol vous avez voyagé dans un
petit peu partout dans le monde et vous
parlez de ses voyages dans vos livres
mais vous parlez aussi de votre voyage
intérieur très juste mais bienvenu quel
a été le déclic justement c'est très
bien parce qu'il ya des gens qui lisent
mes bouquins mais chacun et ils y
trouvent ce qu'ils veulent et à trouver
et à qui dit obama
vous avez des aventures bizarre et vous
avez voyagé l'autre aider à vous avez
fait un voyage intérieur
pris conscience de la condition humaine
oui c'est ça qu'est ce qu'on y trouve
que quand les sur terre pas pour faire
du mal mais pas fallu bien et pour
apprendre apprendre à prendre sans arrêt
on prend des coups très quand on prend
des ailes et des il ya des difficultés
qu'un énorme et des déceptions mais il
faut pas s'accrocher il faut pas
s'accrocher aux déceptions vont remonter
la pente et puis on y arrive et surtout
faux pas avalé des pensées
obsessionnelles oui et je crois ça c'est
un grand tort de beaucoup de gens
d'avoir une obsession je veux me veut
cette cour me veut c'est tant mieux si
cela est concernant ce point tourne pas
rond deviens fou et et on passe à l'acte
pour faire des choses insensées et quand
on va on est en finale passer ça peut
pas aller dans se demande pourquoi
est-ce que c'est pas moi ou est-ce que
c'est pas bon pour toi et moi après ça
c'est comme si l'on prend sa voiture on
va dans une impasse et au bout en bout
et la france interdit par céder mais
tournant vert foncé le mur quand vous
êtes arrivé à la réunion est ce que vous
avez trouvé très différents la réunion
par rapport aux autres pays où vous avez
vécu voyager
on s'attendait un peu plus d'exotisme
après tahiti qui est vrai mais qtx lire
de rêve et les tahitiens sont très et
cela a été fait appel les salles est
tombé de ma chaise rosetta et ont trouvé
les gens plus soucieux c'est au début
soucieux puis plus grave plus mais les
intérêts sont aussi à lever plus de ce
contact de ce point sur le plan
de la conversation et s'était éteint en
sciences tout est beau ce merveilleux
c'est des petits anges les tahitiens
sont descendus du ciel puis se baignent
dans le lagon et puis il n'y a pas de
problème c'est vraiment comme ça alors
là oui c'est comment va au cinéma c'est
vrai est ici c'était moins beau moins en
moins insouciant et
mais c'était bien quand même en été moi
j'ai mis tout de suite je pense que
c'est seulement la rayant 72 la réunion
en 2002 mary ann il ya une grande
différence
la chose la plus horrible pour moi c'est
le racisme de condamner quelqu'un pour
sur la perte appartenance religieuse ou
d'origine ou de peau de couleur cheveux
ou parce qu'ils mangent ceci cela est
pas ce serait pas s'il va la prière
vendredi et d'autres qui vont sur 10 et
c'est tellement idiot alors ça c'est un
racisme religieux il s'agit je n'ai pas
non plus parce que pour moi il ya il ya
un seul dieu tout dans le dit d'ailleurs
réel imaginant le disent les bouddhistes
le disent certains mais plusieurs façons
d
de mieux le servir de la doré de le prix
des terrains chacun s'en sort il ya un
singe aignan qui a dit un homme sans
aucune religion mais qui est bon voilà
vraiment un homme religieux vous parlez
beaucoup de spiritualité et
d'études d'êtres humains dans votre
défense est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
vous influence et je croise assez telle
aventure de ma mère ma tente pourtant de
geert route qui était voyante avec
médium et qui a révélé des choses
incroyables et je n'ai jamais douté
aujourd'hui aux rencontres avec des gens
qui lisent sur 18 dans les ménages aurel
vieille folle et cetera pour moi c'était
tout à fait naturel cioni tellement et
elle était là mais alice est réel pour
moi je les ai maintenant est ce qu'elle
raconte c'est vrai la spiritualité une
grande place dans votre disque faisait
peu de la mort absolument pas un nom la
mort c'est juste un passage on ouvre une
porte on la ferme trouve autre chose de
l'autre côté ça ne me fait pas peur ce
qui me fait peur et la souffrance
souffrance et par mail et non pas du
tout
pour moi toutes ces choses de la vie
après la mort
la réincarnation le contact avec des
êtres du fin c'est réel donc je suis
cartésien puisque parce que je crois et
parce que là j'ai dans ma bibliothèque
je suis pas quoi 50 livres qui traitent
ça qu'ils sont tout ce qu'ils ont vécu
et
mais j'ai okende aucun dans absolument
pas
on avait nos trois enfants ici
malheureusement on a perdu notre fille
aînée ça c'est une chose dont je n'aime
pas trop parler de ça c'est très
douloureux pour tout le monde perdre un
enfant je passais la pire des choses qui
puisse vous arriver mais faut faire avec
aussi est ce que je pourrais dire que
quand vraiment on va que on sent que la
personne est tellement malheureux
tellement malade que la du mal à vivre
il faut se faire une idée dire que
de là-haut prennent à deux enfants qui
sont enseignants ici qu'ils sont et en a
quatre petits-enfants qui sont très
épanouie qui sont totalement tous
métissés les deux conjoints en son
créole et qui sont métissés et très
heureux
vous êtes foraine et vous vendez quoi
oui je suis foraine je suis foraine à mi
temps même un mi temps ils dixième de
manteau parce qu'il faut pas trop gagner
quand on est quand on est retraité on
doit pas dépasser un certain plafond
pour moi c'était un passe temps mais apa
sera utile je continue toujours avant de
vendre regardons
je vends des petits sujets en paix petit
âne immodéré du monde entier défaut bien
musée des bijoux une partie de vos
revenus est reversée pour des familles
en difficulté saab en aide et l
madagascar jérôme à des figures je fais
vivre
de familles des femmes du lien père mère
et deux enfants à pondichéry et je suis
allé les voir tu es allé les voir deux
fois et j'ai mangé chez eux dans
l'aptitude ou la pluie parce qu'entre la
mousson là c'est vraiment la misère
totale les gamins sont à bord de son
père à l'école ils vont lycéens tu ne
devrais acheter un vélo et avant ils
marchent tous les matins 5 km à pied
tous les 2,5 le soir pour revenir de
l'école et là ils sont tous les deux
seulement
est il notre famille que j'ai à lui suis
allé voir aussi dans le hall de mysore
la commande à 2200 km et là aussi on
suit les contrôles et moi même que
l'argent arrive il arrive directement
après une 3e j'ai une petite tibétaine
est encore une fille avec la direction
et à madagascar un malgache une mangue
hp mais comme vous parlez de revenus ils
s'endorment à très modeste parce que je
fais des prix très cool est né et c'est
vraiment pas pour gagner de l'argent
l'action je me fiche complètement c'est
le plaisir de vendre le plaisir de
connaître les gens de sortir peut aussi
des raisins et abat ce contact humain
avec les acheteurs et il reste toujours
une petite monnaie
cela
figure dans
le deuxième livre vous avez fait un
bilan à la fin du livre et pourquoi
l'avoir fait maintenant
pourquoi avoir un vélo mais
j'étais tellement active quand j'étais
enseignant d'à côté j'avais les enfants
les petits enfants qui commencent à
naître est plein d'activités j'étais
visiteuse de prison et sur la solitude
je fais un truc du style remplie
d'activités et où je me suis d où vient
l retraite comment tu vas me rita
retraite maintenant tu vas y avait payé
un peu la fin ce n'est pas du tout la
fin alors je fais un bilan mais
maintenant je me sens en pleine forme je
pense que ça ça continue to fin du mois
ça continue le temps que ça doit
continuer
on